right now dozens of union workers are
staging a walkout over at child haven
the clark county facility it serves
abused and neglected children and staff
there say that the working conditions
they need to improve hector mejia
joining us live this morning with their
demand hector it was early for these
folks but they are awake and they're out
there
it really is you can hear them right now
dozens are out here they say issues have
been going on for a number of years they
say they are understaffed they also say
that employees are being abused by
children and also they say that staff
here are not trained or qualified to
provide children the treatment they need
and take a live look right behind us
this protest here getting underway it's
scheduled to be out here until 7 30 this
morning and they say those issues again
they've been going on for a while the
union saying dfs is understaffed we
reached out to clark county and clark
county said the coronavirus forced them
to pause hiring for almost a year the
county says they're working to catch up
in a written statement it said that over
the last month they hired 29 new people
it also said in part we share union
members concerns regarding the children
with acute mental health issues at child
haven they also say there has been an
ongoing lack of mental health services
across the country and in southern
nevada the county also saying that
they're working to hire more mental
health professionals to meet the
immediate mental health needs of
children in our community and back out
here you see the group here rallying
with chance they are wanting more safety
that's what they say out here so it's
scheduled to be out here until 7 30 this
morning we'll be out here we'll have
another live report for you at 6 30.
reporting live hector mejia live local
now